声がですねこんな感じになったとして
あのすみませんかつれてるんですが実は昨日は全く出なかったんですね
なので今日こうしてお話が出来るってこと自体にまずは感謝をしたいと思うんですが
狭さを率いるお聞き苦しくて最後のプレゼンテーション
なりますを付けください今日ある勝したいと思っているのはまぁ自分が
クルミドコーヒーというカフェをやってきて越の中で今感じている植物が育つようにお
店を作るそういう
テーマです
少し自己紹介をします今44歳なんですけれども
先ほどご紹介もいただいた通り学校データとコンサルティングの仕事をして
ちっちゃいながらベンチャーケッペル投手&の仕事をして餌を磯10年前になります
けれども壁の店主になりました
この振れ幅の大きさということでまあ昔の自分の仕事を知っている仲間からすると多い
影山
何が起こったんだって言う
ねそんな風にも聞かれることがありましたでそういう意味で今日のお話がその質問への
答えの一つになっていけば
ふうに思うんですけれども
あの僕のやってるお店は東京の中央線という線の西の方にあります
西国分寺駅その駅前にあるカフェです
手を見させていただくと写真ご覧いただける通りテーブルの上に
から月の包みが置いてあって
それを自分で割って食べることができるそんな仕組みになっているんですね
でお店を訪ねてくださる大人の方たちの中に眠っているはずの子どもを心にも届くよう
なお店になったらいいなという想いから子どもたちのための壁でその言い方をさせて
もらっています
この辺は自分の仲間が大事な仲間が帰ってくれた絵なんですけれども
おそらく実物よりもよく描けていると思います
でくるみ割り人形ですとかくるみにまつわるさまざまなアイテムが店内に並んでいてお
店に来て下さった方からは
ねえ長い子の中に来たようなそんな感覚がそれなーいっていただける
ことも有難いことにあります
こういう話をしていると自分がいかに
カフェが好きか日目をやりたかっただろうねとさぞかしというふうに言われることが
あるんですけども
実は僕の場合全くそんなことはなくてカフェなんてまったくやりたくなかったんですね
どっちがってコーヒーよりも紅茶のほうが好きなんです
なんですけども気がついたらやることになり10年経ち
実は今僕はカフェをやるために生まれてきたというふうに感じています
重い思い込みが激しいたちなのでね何やっててもそう思ってた可能性あると思うんです
が
カフェには大きな魅力があります
その中でも一つ挙げるとするならばこういうこと
目的もなく人が集まれる場所であるということ
京子の方にお集まりいただいている皆さんはそうではないかもしれませんけれど実は
世の中の多くの人は自分が何に興味があるのか
何に取り組みたいのかと自分のエネルギーを何に使ったらいいのかはっきり言葉になっ
ている人の方がむしろ少ないんじゃないかという気さえするんです
そういう中で壁っていうのは目的もなくふらっと来ることができて自分自身との対話を
深めたり誰かとおしゃべりをする中から自分のアイデアを磨きこんだりそういったこと
で人が育ち
文化が生まれ街が作られていくそういう実は拠点に壁がなっているって事があるように
思うんです
だからこの愛知大府という場所がそうであるようにカフェも一つのインキュベーション
スペースである
いうふうに申し上げていいんだろうと思うんです
でこれは僕がマッキンゼー時代コンサルティングの仕事をしていた当時に帰っていた
ようなグラフ
なんですけれどもお店の過去の売り上げを表しています
立野まあ規模は内緒というふうにさせてもらってますが
タカが知れた額ですで売り上げは14%ずつの成長ということで
決してそんなあの
倍々ゲームのような成長ではないんですただ決して時期的には楽な時期ではなかったん
ですね
リーマンショックがあり東日本大震災もあり
そして消費税の増税なんかもあるなかでもまあはオーガニックな成長を遂げてくること
ができたこれは自分たちなりには誇りに思っていることです
でこうやってこれをあえてスライドを出した1つの理由はこの後にお話しする内容は
聞き方によってはとっても綺麗事に聞こえる
内容だと思うんですただこれは僕のポリシーなんですけれども
綺麗事って中途半端にやるのが一番たちが悪いと思うんです
でもキレイ事本当に入って
弟子であっていけばそれはちゃんと数字を含めた結果にも表れていくということを信じ
ていて
短く小さな単位ではありますけれども自分立つお店でそれを実現してくることができた
のかなというふうに思っているんです
で10年間のカフェの掲揚通じて今日皆さんに申し上げたい内容はこのスライドでご
紹介できます
これまでお店を作ることもそうですあるいはまちをつくることを広げて言えば社会を
創ること全てがですね
いってみれば自動車を作るように光学的なアプローチに基づいて作られてきたように
思うんですね
その様子を図式化するならばこういう三角形
ピラミッドになるかと思うんです自動車の場合には設計図があります
会社の場合には事業計画があるまちづくりの場合は都市計画というものがでその定義さ
れたせいかに向けていかに最短距離でたどり着いていけるかそういうゲームの方が
方をこれまでしてきたんだと思うんですね
でそれが社会の効率化生んだというポジティブな面があることもこれは事実です
ただこれをやり過ぎてしまったことで何が起こったかそれが人間の手段かだったんじゃ
ないかって僕は思ったんですその生み出し大盛況のために貢献できる人は利用価値が
ある人として尊重される
だけど
皆がそうかというとそうではないんだろうと思うんです
そういうなかでどうの人間がどうも部品化して規格化をしていく
そういうことへの疑問を感じていなかった中でカフェというものにめぐり合っ
そこでこの三角形を180度ひっくり返してみようと思ったんですね
これは何の形に皆さん見えますか
これは僕には植物の形に言えるんですね
だからこれまでのやり方を180度変えてむしろ
機械ではなくて植物が育つかのようにお店を作っていくことができないかそんな風に
考えました
で10年前になりますけれどお店を最初に作る時普通お店を企画する時の最初の考えは
まあ市場分析っていうでしょうかね環境分析をしてどういうお店が地域にあるのか
お客さんのニーズがどういうところにあるのかそういったことを分析してお店の業態を
定義していくそれが
万成功の確率を高めるというふうに言われるわけですけれども
僕の場合はそうではありませんでした実はこの渋谷で
まメイクという壁があってそれをやっているオーナーの井川さんからこういう質問をさ
れたんですね
影山くん好きな食べ物何言って
でもがございましたトーモールポスト天津甘栗です
ただそれじゃあ日目にならないねっで他になんかないのと聞かれてまくる女パーン
マーク果物だとなんかパキってコートだするぐらいの愛書が好きです
なことを言っていたらですね香山君それ全部か十本だねと
言われてみれば影山くん見た目もなんかネズミにいてるし
そのネズミぼかりすが燃焼動物書のみ集めてやってるお店をつくったら影山くんぽいん
じゃないのっていう風に言われたんですそれが自宅みどコーヒーの限定なんですね
このことは実は意外に大事なことを教えてくれているを持っていてそれはすなわち自分
の中にタネのあることをちゃんとやろうという
だから市場分析して環境分析して出てくる答えではなくてその答えはあなたの中にある
んじゃないかというふうに
の時に教えてもらったように感じているんです
で合わせて10年間貫いてきた自分なりの一つのテーマこれが give から始める
ということなんですけれどこれはもう少し詳しくご説明していきましょう
例えば僕らの組ドコーヒーではポイントカードのようなものやその10%オフになる
クーポンみたいないょね集客施策と言われるものを一切行っていません
これはなぜなぜかというとそのクーポンを持っていくと10%オフになる
で10回行くと1回の妹のがタダになるそういったインセンティブでお客さんを呼ぼう
とするとどうしてもお客さんの中に眠る
消費者的な人格つまりできるだけ少ない労力でできるだけお得な買い物をしたいと思う
そういう人格を引き出してしまうように思うんですね
お客さんがそういう振る舞いをするようになると僕らお店も同じことを考えます
いかにコストをかけない
以下200円でも200円でも多くとるとるかそういうふうにお互いが徳重すってこと
を考えていく
交友関係がですねあのお互い防衛的にしてしまっているって事があるんじゃないか
それを変えようと思ったんです
ならば自分たちの特のためではなくていかにお客さんに喜んでもらえるか
そのことに徹頭徹尾力を注ぐコーヒーしっかり
ケーキしかりは積極しっかりでそうやっていいサービス良い時間が提供できるとお客
さんの中に眠るこういう人格が発動し始めます自動車的な人
ん
これは聞き慣れない表現だと思うんですけど何か良い贈り物を受け取ったときに何か
良いもの家とちょっとな
そうするとそれ受け取ったもの以上のものって返したくなる
そういう心理っていうのは人間誰しも追っていると思うんですねで実際僕らが良い時間
をお客さんに提供できるときはお客さんの中でこういう事が起
怒るんだと思うんです帰り際にネジでコーヒー飲んでケーキ食べて
1,000円ねお支払いをするただ払った時に何かちょっとせーへんじゃ足りない気が
する
木なんか多くの良いものを受け取ったような気がする
そういうふうに感じる感覚の事を例えば
健全な細君と読んでみたらどうかな
夫妻という言葉ちょっとネガティブなイメージがあるかも知れませんけどなんか返さ
なきゃいけない気になる
これはとっても前向きな心理状態でそうやってギブしたものが give back さ
れることの企画になったきっかけになるでさらに良い関係を始めていくきっかけになる
そのことが実は繰り返しの来店であった
エイ
大店の売り上げであったり数字数字で表れる成果にもつながっていくというふうに思う
んですね
だから世の中のあらゆる関係を今まお店のお客さんとねお店の関係のお話しましたが
これ実はあらゆる場面に当てはまると思うんですけれどもそれらを利用しあう関係で
ヲタがテイクし
の関係からギブしあう関係に変えてみる
これをやってみたらどうかというふうに思っているんです
でこの数字を見て下さい29万9000482これはその文度コーヒーにちょうど昨日
までの時点で実際に足を運んでくださったお客さんのニーズですでこれ一口に言って
しまえば決して大きな数字ではないとは思うんです
ただこのお一人お一人に僕らは合ってるんです
を1
81人と顔を合わせてでそこで自分たちに出来る
give が何なのかってことを考えて時間を提供する
そういった関わり合いが30万回積み重ねたが重ねられるということのインパクトの
大きさはこれは実は小さくないものなんじゃないかって思っているんです
でそういうやり取りの中から実際に思いがけずお客様の中で本を書いている人が文章を
書ける人がいたので出版業が始まったり
あるいは哲学カフェと言われたりしますけれども
日曜の朝に集まってコーヒー片手にですね a
哲学的な対話をする機会まあこういったモノを申す260回ぐらいやってくることが
できました
こういったことを積み重ねていく中からです今自分はっきり意識している経営上の方法
論が一つあります
では需要計画を作らないということです
これはもともと僕の墓所エクスパティズと言った方が良いようなものだったわけです
けれど事業計画がはっきりあって今月の優先事項はこの3つだということがはっきりし
ていればしているほど
スタッフの意識がそこにパック出向いてしまうんですねも日目の面白さは日々いろんな
人が訪れて思いがけない出会いが
やっぱり思いがけない相手がそこで生まれてくる
そういうことがカフェの魅力であるのに事業計画があることがむしろそういったことを
キャッチするセンサーを萎えさせてしまう
であるならば授業見学なってない方がいいむしろ一杯一杯のコーヒー屋
一人ひとりのお客さんに整備パイのベストを尽くしていくということの向こう
にこそ魅力的な未来は待っているというふうにもう
今お店とお客さんとの関係としてお話をしました
同じ実はスタッフとの関係っていうのもあるのですね
これは世の中の事業体を見ていくととても周りに対して
ギビングにネリカ的な事業をやっている組織などに残念なラグ残念ながら口が上向くと
その
を目的達成の為にスタッフを主題にしてしまっている
そういうケースもあるように思うからですだからお客さんに対してギブをするように僕
らはスタッフに同一部できるかそれも考えるわけです
さらにその外側には地域もある出てきますが
すべてのスタッフに最初にしている質問があります
例えば
オープン以来天地をやってくれていた4姉妹スタッフん今も社員でてくれますけれども
あのいます
よしまくんっていうのはクルミドコーヒーのために別にいるわけじゃない
4島久雄くんっていう人が先にいて
その人生の道すがらの一つの表現のチャンスとして
今クルミドコーヒーにいてくれるよねじゃあこの場合はこの機会を使ってよ芝くんは何
を表現してみたいと思う
そういうふうに効くんですねで最初はほとんどの人がうまく答えられませんだけど
繰り返しそれを問うていくうちにちょっとずつその人の中に眠っていた
た種が芽をたし始めるということが送ります
そういうことを積み重ねてきた結果お店で始まってきた様々な海のリストはこちらです
今日は1行1行を説明する時間はありませんけれども
すべての取り組みの向こうにこういう名詞のスタッフがいてそのスタッフがいたから
こそ実現できたという
事柄いってみればそういう生命力に満ちた事柄でお店が満ちていった
そういう10年間すぐに振り返ることはできるだろうと思います
これはこれまで自分が系コンサルタントの仕事等で教わってきた
方法論をひっくり返すことでまいります
その経営の教科書の中ではこう教えられました仕事を属人化するな
仕事業務フローを標準化してそこに人を当てていく
コレは確かに一つの方法論なわけですただそれをやりすぎると結果的にあなたがいなく
なっても二日三日後には別の人がやってきて全く何事もなかったどのように仕事は続い
ていく
つまりあなたは替えがきくの総会が利く存在なんだということを日々の仕事がその日
入ってしまっているように僕は思う
そうだ後それを逆転させるその人がいたからこそ実現する仕事っていうものに光を当て
ていく
このことを伝えするとじゃあその人がいなくなったらどうするのってことは聞かれます
ただこれも植物的なイメージで考えればいいと思っていてそれでも幹は残るのですね
まりに枝が落ちたとしてもその落ちた枝から松木の枝が生えてくる
そういうその破壊と再生を繰り返してお店屋町8
赤いは育っていくものだと思うのでそこを順番を間違えないのが大事じゃない
最後に少しだけ地域の話国分寺をめぐっている高地域通貨がありますぶんじという名前
です
名市大
ねあの街のためにゴミ拾いをしたりお祭りのボランティアをしたりそうするとこういう
のがもらえるわけなんですけど
で国分寺市内を中心にいま40カ所ぐらい使えるお店があります僕らのお店もその一つ
でただ使うとき一つだけルールがあって
下の方のぞよく見ていただくと吹き出しがあるんですね
そこにメッセージを書くことになっています
でしたがってそれが埋まっていくとこんな s 形になっていきます
えお車ありがとうクルミドコーヒーいつも素敵な空間をありがとう
だからその自分が受け取った仕事に対しての感謝の気持ちがその通貨の上に表現されて
手渡されるんですね
これを受け取れるようになる僕らの中で何が起こる
そのその日そういう受け入れ受け取ることが上手な人その工程の感謝の気持ちの表も
表明してくれる人がいることで贈る側の張り合いが出てくるんですね
もっと良い時間を追って教室もっと良い美味しいケーキ作ろ
そうやって受けてが送りてを育てていく
でそうすると町の中のあらゆるし人の仕事や働きに意味が変わっていきます
最初のころはそうではなかったはずだろうに行っていくちんだんだんお金の為自分の為
っていう風になってしまうお店も改めてどうしたらお客さんを喜ばせられるかな
そういう give の気持ちをこの通貨を使うことをきっかけにもう1回行きがつい
ていくそんなことが起こっているわけですね
だから今日は利用しあう関係から支援し合う関係
それはお店とお客さんもスタッフとも地域ともあらゆる場所での関係をそういうふうに
作り直して言ったら何が起こるだろうかそういうご提案です
で
街であり社会はこういう定義もできると思うんです
交換の集合体
からたかだか石国分寺の知らない僕らのお店単位でも30万回という単位の効果の
チャンスがあったわけですそれを持って広げて行ったときにその1回1回の交換が
生み出す意味を180度変えることができたならその積み重ねが社会にもたらす
ファクトはとても大きいもの
大きいものになるとちん子ています
今日ぜひこのイメージだけでも持ち替えていただきたい持ち帰っていただけたらと思っ
ているのはこの300系ピラミッドのイメージをひっくり返す
でその時に出会ったね雨が振ったり光が射したり刺さなかったり虫が飛んで来ない鳥が
飛んできたり
そういう出会いの中で自然と伸ばすべき枝を伸ばすように
人が育ちお店が育ち町が育っていくそういう方法論に僕らはもう1回見直していく時期
差し掛かっているのではないかと思うんです
これからのお店の成長町の成長渋谷に負けない街に国分寺もしていきたいとおもいます
どうか温かく見守って頂けたらと思いますご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]